the closed mind is  is not driven because the closed mind is  certain and and certain minds aren't  curious and they're not seeking what's  next they weren't seeking what could be  ultimately it comes down to the  questions we ask ourselves how might i  be wrong  how am i what what might this person be  feeling you know that what might this  person be experiencing that i'm not  open-mindedness can be accessed by  almost anybody you know just by asking  the right question can i just let me  give this person the situation this um  this event a chance and  and let me start seeing what might be uh  what might be positive about that let me  see it in a different light you know and  that's those are really those are really  powerful questions to ask and and ones  that can help open  open your mind quite a bit curiosity is  the buttress to open minders